c'est un geste que les yvelinois comme
tous les français ne seront pas amenés à
faire avant les prochaines semaines
glisser un bulletin dans une urne ne se
fera finalement pas ce dimanche 22 mars
le parlement va voter dans les heures
qui viennent en projet de loi qui va à
la fois permettre en effet le report du
second tour des élections c'est dans le
premier tour il est considéré comme
acquis et donc on va prendre des
dispositions pour le report des
dispositions pour les conseils aussi
communautaire d'agglomération pour que
ça puisse continuer à fonctionner aussi
normalement que possible et que les
services publics et bien évidemment il
ya une continuité deuxième tour annulé
ce sont sept communes saint-quentinoise
qui sont concernés
villepreux plaisir les clayes-sous-bois
trappe voisins-le-bretonneux la verrière
ou encore guyancourt on l'attendait déjà
pendant la journée d'hier bien
évidemment donc on a on n'a pas vraiment
été surpris hier soir
maintenant je pense que cette décision
est parfaitement sage et que voilà on
pourra se consacrer totalement à la
lutte contre le virus durant les
semaines et peut-être les mois à venir
cinq communes ont en revanche je suis un
maire élu au premier tour le dimanche 15
mars
elles doivent organiser un tout premier
conseil municipal à huis clos comme à
magny les hameaux auront donc
l'installation du nouveau conseil
municipal ce samedi à l'hôtel de ville à
huis clos puisque à priori c'est de la
comptine qui devrait arriver mais on se
prépare dès maintenant et on essaye de
travailler pas de côté sur une aux
transmissions internet et ses conseils
d'installation doivent se tenir d'ici ce
dimanche 22 mars